[Musik]
viel spaß die hin und weg wünscht de
erhält können
[Musik]
ihr schweizer ab 450 sorten käse in
sambia haben wir zwei
einer ist orange und den anderen mag ich
nicht mal anfassen
[Musik]
im touristenort am roten meer hätte sich
kein erklärt der ägypter weil und schwyz
recurring er hat als notfallmediziner
schaffen sie im luxushotel
er begegnet mit folge 22 jahre sind
geräte und ein 24 meter hindernis mal
schauen die resonanz dieses bildlich
zimmer geholt ohne geschätzte 7 als
jedes mal war danach immer ich sagen
ein verrückter liebesgeschichte wurde
ihr beide vor sharm el sheik of chicago
und schließlich aufgebraucht hat
[Musik]
albufeira morgen aber phx brangelina der
wahl startet mit dem fitnessprogramm
anderthalb stunden darf fast jeden tag
das ist die einzige zeit am tag an dem
ich was machen kann
ich brauche den sport um arbeiten zu
können sonst verliere ich energie 50 und
sportmediziner zweimal mit seiner frau
corinna in eigener praxis in kairo
[Musik]
wenn es cool das ist so trug statt und
das macht das wirklich hören aber also
irgendwas nicht durch drei typen ihren
die figur drei meter tief dann geht es
zum verkauf ich dachte wie eine kleine
pfeife wäre zeit
ich brauche sie nach dem training
sie hasst es ist sechs uhr früh sind für
das bild der schweiz
[Musik]
der hub ist im süden vertreibung in
regiert community anderer bewachte
wohnsiedlung mit einer gibt es viel über
20 millionen statt
[Musik]
es sind nur ein paar kilo mehl du bist
du der praxis aber die beiden demo mit
dem taxi am anfang von mir selbst doch
es wurde zunehmend zum kampf momentan
ist noch kein verkehr aber in einer
stunde wird es wirklich hart
wir wollen entspannt in der praxis
ankommen
[Musik]
bz der hauptstadt vorgibt
vorher sind vier jahren us sie derweil
hat in chicago es studium zum
chiropraktiker gemacht
[Musik]
ich trage drei schichten die erste
schützt die brille vor dem beschlagen
die zweite ist besonders dicht und die
dritte bewahrt die mittlere vor
verschmutzern bei unabsichtlicher
berührung
wir sind sehr vorsichtig und ich
betrachte jeden patienten als infiziert
klar ist für die organisation zuständig
derweil kümmert sich um patienten trägt
die einlagen sieht gut aus
beide und da auch wenn ihre
öffnungszeiten für ägypter alles andere
als normal sind wirklich auffangen und
dora ziehen und dann haben wir es den
seitengassen darum kann man sie so früh
am morgen und bin hammam halben und der
als kilo praktika behandelte weil
patienten mit problemen bewegungsapparat
und viertel vor zehn als in die praxis
musste hat ist da einfach der erste mit
ihrer spezialisierung sie mit patienten
aus dem ganzen arabischen raum
[Musik]
also ist es die heiße sambia für den
moment und mir geht es so wie man ist
wohl fühlen aber mir gesagt dass man
sich einmal an wenn die schweiz wenn die
familienplanung und so im raum steht ist
es auch für mich einfach wichtiger dass
das er nach dem spiel ins schweizer auf
schulbildung und so
vom kanton thurgau auf sambia
größer könnte der kontrast forschen sie
für miriam ist das alltag von gut zwei
jahre als die datensammler chris keine
gelernt ihren zukünftigen ehemann ins
partei zu sambia liegt im südlichen teil
von afrika
das land ist arm erst elf die für die
menschen muss mit weniger als zwei
dollar am tag ausruhen
weißt du was das ist das ist nicht
scharf oder paprika ist nicht scharf
und was ist das das ist chili man kann
ihn mit eukalyptus blättern mission
vor ausbau minute ist der kreis zum
ersten mal in der schweiz
für miriam ist es wichtig dass er auf
ihre heimat kennt gerade wild
unterschiede so groß sind
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
meistens der krise das ist weiß man
manchmal 100 wohlfühlen weil man einfach
so schnell weil man halt einfach ufert
wichtiger gemacht
ja und dann ist für mich immer einfach
wenn ich einfach volle kasse bieten aber
mittelbar spricht und nicht eigentlich
schade dass ich den schönsten war dass
gott die ich verstehe miriam jetzt viel
besser weil ich das selbe in der schweiz
erlebt habe auch wenn mich die leute
nicht angesprochen haben spürte ich dass
sie viele fragen
wir konnten jedoch nicht miteinander
sprechen
das fühlte sich seltsam an
nicht nur tut habe ich im alltag immer
wieder das thema sondern als geld als
vielmehr und fotograf für die ente chris
klug für das leben in sambia schweizer
coop miriam einfach normales ganz andere
finanzielle verhältnisse in der schweiz
lernt man schon von klein auf wie man
geld sparen kann
hier ist das anders wegen der schlechten
wirtschaftlichen lage leben die menschen
von der hand ich wuchs damit auf die
dinge zu schätzen die ich habe sicher
hat miriam mehr geld als ich aber das
spielt für mich keine rolle als mann bin
ich in der lage dafür zu sorgen dass es
immer genug zu essen gibt und es sie
auch sonst nichts fehlen wird
ich bin ja soo personelle vorteil ich
dachte also schon früh oder wo nicht
angefangen dann studiere ich mir
vorstelle dass ich mal mehr da bin wo
nicht unbedingt geheim schumi sondern
halten am zug nach gott und vielleicht
auch mehr verdient als thema vor der
show bevor ich ihn überhaupt nicht
irgendwie komisch so oder so für mich
und normalen und okay für mich
eigentlich mit viel gelassenheit und
zuversicht könnt ihr beide ihre
gemeinsame zukunft entgegen
[Musik]
und also helft mir eigentlich ja also
ist mit dem islam in der schweiz oder
diskussionen noch alle in englisch
da würde ich mal nicht ganz einfach
[Musik]
wie der evelyn in sursee als koffer
packen
erst vor knapp sechs monaten mit ihrer
familie von york runne alles packt und
ist
danny ist vielen produzent und auch der
korona flaute endlich wieder was neues
projekt auf den tisch der jury für
netflix wo im osten der usa treibt wird
als da konnten wir halle berry
verpflichten
aber wir sind noch an anderen leuten
dran
deren namen ich aber noch nicht sagen
kann was brauchen wir noch befindliche
windeln sommer spielzeit
die können wir auch dort besorgen bücher
bücher habe ich eingepackt vielleicht
eine decke die habe ich auch schon
es ist sorge um ihre familie xiii und
evelyn vos und corona blog der new york
und zurück
als schauspielerin und sängerin ist
evelyn als lebe aus dem koffer gewöhnt
aber auf der welt ist alles liebe so
einfach wäre mit dem projekt sind dann
entscheiden wir das zusammen und ich es
wirklich richtig wird vom medium zu
bieten aber ich bin mit gott und ich
kann die luft
ich kann ja job und ich bin genau wie
ich bin oder so ich bin immer bei dem
job bin ich reise und sich alles anders
komplett anders und der natur nicht
wirklich nicht so finde ich schon mal
als ist ausdrucksvoll und das ist das
problem
also absolvierte nicht so
angehende dass das jetzt wirklich für
mich so beschwerlich jetzt schon etwas
in mir ist rastlos
ich kann mich nicht fest niederlassen
ich muss immer in bewegung sollen du
musst aber auch bisher musstest du das
für den job
einmal wurde mir ein fester job in einem
büro angeboten
dasselbe gehalt wahrscheinlich sogar
mehr und ich habe abgesagt
es stimmte für mich einfach nicht
diesmal habe ich habe auch nicht das
gefühl dass wir alles abbrechen
die schweiz ist für mich dauerhafter ob
es immer so sein wird das weiß ich nicht
[Musik]
evelyn wünscht sich es meist führt
familie unter den ort wo noch ein schock
und dann ist da oder evelyn ihre eigene
karriere
kurz vor der abreise ein fotograf hat
sie braucht neue bilder zum web sieht
den frischen 25 geordneten weil er sich
immer noch als aufgezeigt wird
berlin hofft dass sie in den usa und
kanada
die macher der werbung film und theater
ist einfach die möglichkeit sich nicht
aber wenn dann endet in dre segment also
da doch als ich doch als ich sie spontan
natürlich jetzt spielt die hauptrolle
[Musik]
balance zwischen der ewl in ihrer
karriere im sinne projekt und inlays in
der bedürfnis münster stoff linde
[Musik]
ich dachte nicht wirklich an
konsequenzen
ich hatte nur augen für kurier- und
ihren charakter passen wir zusammen wird
es eine erfolgsgeschichte sei und jede
herausforderung zeigte umso mehr
ja wir sind füreinander geschaffen
[Musik]
dass crysis 2 wird hätte sich gewiss
derweil kennengelernt
[Musik]
kairo ist die größte stadt des
afrikanischen kontinents sie schwarz
ziehen ihren laut und chaotisch
[Musik]
noch immer lange da die arztpraxis and
green und derweil vier ob ich sie für
ihre marine bahr mit blick aufs wort
sein vorgibt
über 2500 jungs ins art pyramide von
gizeh und gehöre zu der älteste baum
interessanterweise glauben viele die
pyramiden wären in der wüste dabei sind
sie mittlerweile direkt am stadtrand
warum seid ihr überhaupt nach kairo
gezogen
ich glaube dass der nabel der welt am
mittelmeer liegt
die kinder sollten die wahl haben
stell dir vor sie wohnten in kairo haben
in den staaten geliebt und sie kennen
auch die schweiz es geht darum eine
umfassende persönlichkeit zu formen
ehrlich gesagt war es auch ein
finanzieller aspekt aber dennoch bei
micro sind ist arabische frühling ist
revolution heute möglich wäre richtig
gut das geht aus der bürger reagiert das
neue regierung
also können wir sozis kommen glaube also
der vor allem mitternacht der hat ja
nicht mit schlafen will
du hast du kirschbaum und die hand so
ein weiterer grund sind sind diese
unfälle und dass das hat wahnsinnig denn
wir sind immer auch gleich sie ich kann
das auch ein schmuckstück wenn ich ein
gefälschter nicht klar
ich kann meine tasche nachdem becker ich
komme in laptops und und weggegangen um
das in grenzen
das war ein seltsames gefühl
ich fragte mich wozu ich bereit bin um
einer familie zu verteidigen
bist du gewählt jemanden zu verletzten
oder sogar noch weiter zu dienen
ich merkte ich hätte kein problem
jemanden zu verletzen der meiner familie
etwas antun will
direkt danach verschob sich die macht zu
den muslimbrüdern
sie waren natürlich nicht qualifiziert
sein land zu führen
wir wussten das wird nicht lange gut
gehen
nichts ist nachhaltig die stromausfälle
der mangel an wasser und elektrizität
doch die dinge änderten sich dramatisch
und sehr schnell
der preis dafür war hoch
nun haben wir eine militärregierung aber
zumindest konnten wir im land bleiben
[Musik]
wie der merian und im chris in sambia
sind nur noch essbar tag bis zu der
hochzeit als fest mit allen bode
zugekehrt hochzeitskleid und der zug ins
schulamt kauft jetzt fehlt nur noch
styling der chris wend für den großen
tag spezielle frisur so ich möchte mir
die haare flechten lassen damit ich an
der hochzeit gut aussehe
[Musik]
es mache ihr werdet england obhut flucht
auch miriam endtermin sie gott die
pediküre vorfreudig das hochzeitsfest
ich beiden riesig miriam nötigung
einfach wird
es wird herausforderungen geben wenn ich
in die schweiz ziel werde ich alles
verlassen was ich kenne meine kultur
menschen aus essen
ich würde etwas komplett neues beginnen
das wäre für jeden schwierig man kommt
an einen punkt an dem man bereit ist
opfer zu bringen
in der schweiz wird williams familie zu
meiner familie werden aber daran werde
ich mich gewöhnen aber natürlich hoffe
ich dass ich mich völlig in die kultur
integrieren kann
im spark miriam abgemacht mitre kollegin
aus deutschland wo aus sambia schaffen
weil die wüste wie sie spart ford im
gegensatz zum kreis wo in der schweiz
sind das einfach da der das kommunale
einfach fällt und einfach so der
gemeinschaft auch wenn schweizer
gemeinschaft herr klein dafür hat aber
einfach noch mal auf ganz andere art und
wie es ist und ich habe mir mal sind die
eigentlich sprach mit über dem reeder
sprach redet oder sas wo halt die
heizung bereitet wird die fashion shows
wo er wird zeit dass wird ist für sie
aber darum herum denn wahrscheinlich
schon auch schwierig wird für ihn
[Musik]
wie geht es euch wir sind total
entspannt ich bin auch fertig unsere
beiden kulturen sind unterschiedlich ich
würde nicht sagen dass sie zueinander
passen
aber die unterschiede erweitern unseren
horizont
[Musik]
btv bn und im franzis in hawaii dezember
auf der erste blick im rössli noch
ferien muss
[Musik]
der monteur mit der philippinischen
wurzeln und sachbearbeiter aus dem
glarnerland genieße die ihren freien tag
[Musik]
im alltag gibt es bei punkt was
möglichem einig sind
aber der unterschied bringen findet ich
habe aufgehört konserven zu kaufen
mit essen aus der dose bin ich
aufgewachsen weil es günstig aber und
einfach zuzubereiten
fabian hat mich überzeugt dass das
ungesund ist
das ist eine der sachen die ich in
meinem leben für sie geändert habe aber
spam es sich immer noch dosenfleisch ist
grässlich
auch fabienne hat von francis plant sie
mit sportlich aber es hat keine eile
etwas zu erledigen
wenn man an den strand geht muss man
nicht zu einer bestimmten zeit dort sein
der strand wird immer da sein so
verschieden sie auch sind die beiden
schnell gemerkt großzügig sie und
kompromiss sieger das buch zum können
glücklich werde mit genannt
um eine andere art von glück kurz in san
francisco nämlich um darf forint neuen
schwester fabienne macht sich bereit
ich muss mich leider können wir jetzt
ein fasching wird und normalerweise
ganztag machen natürlich schminken und
alles aber neulich kindergärtnerin anna
die sprachenschule noch acht lange
wochen in der schweiz ist nur froh dass
sie wieder zurück wie ihrem frühen die
der usa ist bald sieben jahren sind die
zwei usb video games spielen online gang
oder sexy richter in husum mit technik
zur hand und ich stelle meine energie.de
musiker und glied und sachen und ich was
mir gut tut nicht im kurz und umgekehrt
auch und ich akzeptiere grüne treffen
liegt im moment nicht drin
aber da führen die beiden dank home
office mäßig führen und das ist es womit
dann hatte man das letzte jahr zu
weihnachten geschenkt sondern herzlich
und evers hat entwickler und
flaschenöffner und ja nicht du hast
alles auf google umgestellt oder
du kannst alexa sagen alexa schalte die
lichter aus
[Musik]
sie trügerisch duell in san francisco
die high vorher eine fernbeziehung führt
neulich erst übergegangen das
arbeitsvisum klarheit die unabhängigkeit
ist ihr wichtig ich hatte mich so auf
den wein gefreut
[Musik]
ich bin irgendwo angestoßen
sie fiel einfach raus ich kann die
tasche nehmen
pass auf mit den scherben glück ich
glaube so eine sache
der himmel ist der total schwarz es wäre
toll und wenn sie es nicht trotzdem für
absurd
sie haben nicht gesagt das ist heute
regnen die dunkel es dort ist lasst uns
besser zusammen packen wir verschieben
es auch nächstes wochenende momentan
haben wir viel zeit und dann nehmen wir
zwei weinflaschen mit
es hat nicht sein sollen
es wird uns hassen
wenn ich da
[Musik]
anstatt picknick im park auf der
luftmatratze improvisiere sind wie bei
gekrönt
[Musik]
sie ein genie krise müsse meister as its
time sind nicht wie sie sich nötigen
stoff sondern einfach nur darum wie es
unterschiedlicher sein während jetzt
sofort oder gemacht und ja ich finde
dass man vor zwei verschiedene landes
ist immer im regen das problem sie wird
einfach einfach amerika der schweizer
schon mir einfach so da bin ich wirklich
so eine punkt kommunizieren warum
einfach wenn ich ein schweizer touristen
und total werden
es hat dies wieder mehr verbunden und so
sachen verbindet einfach und dann
geschah metro und glaubt an metro das
ist wichtig ist und die richtig legal
was draußen in der welt passiert wir
können immer zusammen kommen das löst
nicht alle probleme aber gemeinsam
können wir zumindest unsere batterien
wieder aufladen
zuhause finden wir die liebe die wir
brauchen
[Musik]
die
als arzt hätte wahrlich viel freizeit
wenn es um mode passt streift mit seiner
kamera durch aufgewachsen als sohn von
rehkopp den unterricht karte weils
ägypter zum 3 als junge marga 100 liter
aber ich mache es für ihn keinen
unterschied
es ist ein land voller kontraste
es gibt das teure das billige sehr
schmutziges und blitzsauberes der
kontrast ist dramatisch und das liebe
ich
corinne ist im kanton zürich und im
welschland groß wurde
996 sie verübte schafe zwei jahre bevor
sie derweil keine gelernt hat exzellent
bin ich gesund 28 grad
ich sollte zum arzt was hat chorin
schweizer kultur in dein leben gebracht
was es ohne sie nicht gäbe ist extrem
gut organisiert
ohne die welt verloren
finanziell mit den rechnungen die
geburtsurkunden der kinder
du solltest dir ablagesystem sehen damit
habe ich nichts zu tun
sie kümmert sich um 1 ohne sie wäre ich
verloren
es gibt doch sicher auch dinge bei denen
wir kompromisse eingehen musste
es braucht nicht viel wenn es harte
arbeit gewesen wäre hätte es nicht
funktioniert
man fühlt es von anfang an braucht es
grosse anstrengungen wird es nicht
klappen
ihr seid 22 jahre verheiratet immer noch
zusammen und glücklich wie es scheint
wie macht ihr das keiner von uns
beansprucht ein festes territorium
wir teilen uns einen kontinent alles ist
möglich wir können über alles sprechen
und es neu verhandeln und wir achten
nichts als selbstverständlich
man muss sich die neugier bewahren und
dann läuft es von alleine
flexibel bleiben das ist was ich allen
raten wenn ich eine beziehung mit einer
frau beginne dann muss es etwas
ernsthafter sein denn nicht will ihre
gefühle nicht verletzen
der weg war also klar aus der freundin
wird die verlobte und dann kommt die
hochzeit und dort lernte ich sie kennen
und wusste sie ist es
[Musik]
der softwareriese hat wurde hauptstadt
lusaka sich miriam und christmas jahr
wollte die familie ihre freunde und ihre
ältere sind office bauträger kleist
trauzeuge von chris kramer da das ist
miriam und das sind ihre freundinnen
julia und rebecca später wirst du auch
noch die familie treffen
jetzt bin ich entspannter wo die jungs
da sind bisher aber nicht nur von frauen
umgeben und verstand auch die sprache
nicht
das war sehr anstrengend du hörst du
weißt aber nicht wovon sie sprechen
jetzt kann ich einfach beim bau medien
sprechen und das freut mich
familien von chris konnte erst am
hochzeitstag 78 kilo schwere schlicht
tür mit dem wilfried sihn trauerzüge ist
der kreis aufgewachsen
das werden wir morgen für die party
benutzen
er sollte miriam immer wie eine
schweizerin behandeln und nicht
versuchen sie in eine sammlerin zu
verwandeln
das wichtigste aber ist glückliche frau
entspanntes leben
so werden sie es gut miteinander haben
basta
aber es wurde ein recht für hofer oder
ja ich glaube darum ich glaube es wäre
schon verstanden was er sucht weiter hat
miriam sambia kunden ich eigentlich
nicht so groß
ich habe richtig wärmen und ich würde
die prinzessin ich leid seiten so schön
genau
ja und dann stark von der zeit nach
amerika aber ich kann es denn keine
anderen zeremonie findet verrußte stadt
mit der hochzeitsplaner bespricht miriam
noch der ablauf 7 / dass der schweiz und
sambia 1
hier verläuft teppich und der boden
wie werdet ihr die stühle aufstellen wie
viele reihen wird es geben immer fünf
kuraja meisten freue ich mich einfach
bei die teil oder bei die welt dass er
gesetzt malz verbinde also ich meine die
schweizer freunde und meine familie aber
ich habe freunde und familie und die
halbe chance das nicht aber es ist
schwer jetzt auch wieder im moment weiß
ich alles wirklich kennenlernen und sich
erst einmal gesehen
ich glaube da ist als auch im moment für
mich schön ich einfach zum ammersee sind
jetzt und da heißt auch dass familie und
freunde quasi dazu gehört
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da der große tag von chris und miriam
der geübte ist derweil mit dem ticket
unterwegs
chorin und er baut sich als neues
tierheim
[Musik]
boston
das ist hin und weg
mal
die geldpolitik machen
[Musik]
hinunter
präsentiert wurde von dr oetker